the trailer for ghostbusters afterlife
the fourth movie in the franchise
counting that non-canon 2016 one is
finally here
it features callbacks galore but plenty
of these are so free fancy so that
they're easy to miss but don't be afraid
of no ghost busters nostalgia be ready
to believe us about these crucial
details from the trailer down on her
luck Callie has exhausted their
employment opportunities and money in
the big city
so she packs up her teenage son Trevor
and twin daughter Phoebe to make the
trip across the country to a dilapidated
old Oklahoma farmhouse the only thing
left of the family by their dear
deceased conspicuously unnamed
grandfather we learned from the
wonderfully named summer school teacher
Mr Gruber CERN that the town has become
plagued by sudden and frequent
earthquakes despite his considerable
distance from tectonic plates and
absence of loud music during one of
those tremors as a callback to an early
scene in the original Ghostbusters as
the earth starts to shake around Trevor
and his family we see some buds stags
are necessarily high in the background
you may recall that in the 1984 flick
one of the team's first encounters with
the malevolent spirits comes as they
investigates weird occurrences at the
New York Public Library where they find
a bunch of books stacked in such a
manner symmetrical book stacking just
like the Philadelphia man turbulence of
1947 those ominous these doctor books
seem to be the Hereward of supernatural
activity once again Paul Rudd who plays
mr. Gruber's CERN gets a lots of face
time in the trailer and it certainly
looks like his character will serve a
significant purpose he's a die-hard
Ghostbusters fanboy and he's got the
background info to help our young heroes
understand what the heck is going on in
their new town when Phoebe discovers one
of the Ghostbusters or traps hidden in
the family farmhouse she brings it to
school to puzzle over along with one of
her classmates Mr Gruber Sam proclaims
it a quote
killer replica as he explains further we
hear a fluttery and obtrusive piano
motif it's the exact same motif that
Ghostbusters injects into its core a
sing start to get really creepy in the
library we soon see the excitable
teacher pulling up old video of the
Ghostbusters to show to the kids as he
explains there hasn't been a ghost
sighting in 30
New York knees it's like the walking
dead
he pointedly as Phoebe if her dad ever
mentioned this to which the girl replies
I only have mamas around
we then see Phoebe descending via
fireman's pole to an underground chamber
in the farmhouse analyzing the
surroundings were the device that
strongly resembles a PKE meter she
explains my grandfather died my mom says
we're just here to pick through the
rubble of Slice Gruber certain examines
a ghost trap as it begins to glow green
as he wonders just who Phoebe really is
a quick look at that might offered some
clue okay we'll just say it
Phoebe bears are pretty strong
resemblance to Egon Spengler the only
original Ghostbuster whom we know for
sure won't be making an appearance in
this film since Howard Ramos who plays
Egon passed away in 2014
could Kali trevor and phoebe be the
Spangler family we don't have ESP or
anything but there are definitely some
clues as Phoebe picks through all of the
stuff scattered about the house we see a
number of labeled petri dishes sitting
on a table examining them very closely
we can see that they contain things such
as photo sporran micro CRO Nydia and us
for Djilas fumigatus and Egon certainly
expressed an interest in that kind of
stuff do you have any hobbies I collect
spores molds and fungus Phoebe also
conveniently finds a rack in a closet
where hanged all the Ghostbusters old
uniforms we can only make out the name
tag on the first one though Spengler and
that's all of this is seriously hardcore
misdirection we're pretty sure that dear
old granddad was none other than Egon
himself it even makes sense that he
would have brought this property in the
middle of nowhere occurs as he would
have been well aware there have
apparently been strange goings-on here
for a long time later on in the trailer
of Phoebe and a classmate approached the
entrance to an old mine that you
probably should have paid closer
attention to those road closed and no
trespassing signs but another sign in
the distance is even more alarming to
eagle-eyed fans
it reads Shandor mining company and if
you love Ghostbusters this name will set
off all sorts of alarms as he gone
explains when the Ghostbusters are
jailed after their containment unit was
shut down
Evo Shandor wasn't just a mining magnate
he was an architect the very same one
who designed the skyscraper in which
Dana Barrett live
the building referred to by stance as
spook central shandola
actually wore a lot of different hats he
was also a doctor performed a lot of
unnecessary surgery and then in 1920 he
started a secret society that secret
society worshiped gozer the gozerian
the ancient evil entity which was
threatening the Big Apple with utter
destruction at that very moment and
speaking of the gose Aryan before
transforming into the Stay Puft
Marshmallow Man and wreaking terrible
havoc on New York goes I was first
assured into our plane of existence by
vinz clortho the keymaster and zahl the
gatekeeper these entities possessed
Lewis Tully and Dana respectively which
caused them both to mutate into giant
hideous supernatural creatures which the
ghostbusters fandom has dubbed terror
dogs okay in one very quick shot in the
trailer we see GRU person in his car at
night being menaced by a creature all we
see as its giant scaly paw and it sure
looks familiar it appears that the
terror dogs and therefore Vincent's all
are back in business and their business
is to facilitate the coming of gozer the
destructor it's also worth noting what
the trailer didn't show us the original
surviving Ghostbusters whom we know will
be taking part in the madness of
afterlife as the spot concludes with
Trevor Phoebe and Phoebe's buddy tearing
around town in ecto-1 letting loose of
their proton pack while pursuing what
appears to be a class 5 full roaming
vapor we know that these kids have
plenty of moxie if goes our the go zero
and it's on its way back to earth though
they're going to need all the help they
can get and when there's something
strange in your neighborhood who you
gonna call check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about upcoming movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]